Nói mẹ đi, đưa mình ra sẽ phải vừa gịt luôn.
Tìm mình ra là mấy mảnh.
Mì quế, bắt ra.
Tế thì tường mắt sẽ khách để quế.
Sẽ khách thì được gái là cập phải chung.
Mẹn xin viên mà.
Với tội là phải chung trận.
Trung tâm đánh xe nó có một tí.
Cả là sẽ khách thì mấy tất, nó đồng, mấy trên chúc.
Tìm hai lỗi khi cái đợi thất nó không trận.
Lúc khi chấn nó đi xe vừa, cái đi muộn đâm đà là mình tận phải đến xe mơn.
Trời sáng, cho nó chắc.
Dù thì nhẹn tâm nóa, nó mình gặp tập trên này đêm.
Trò lợi thất đường.
Thật ra là mình có rất là sự là bị tối.
Cái không có tài.
Nên là mình cũng lập trước trên xe, trên ác ráp luôn.
Để cho chúng đậu và đậu có một phần thời gian.
Vậy thì có mấy là mả hệ chỉ sẻ quốc hệ hơn.
Vậy thì nhắc đặc trước trên xe.
Vậy hả hả hả hả hả hả hả hả hả?
Đây nhá, mặt có thể là xe tổ đá mầy,
Ngày hỏi hỏi tủ thường bệnh.
Dù jednak vehicles sẻ sẻ lớn đi.
M rub, g oven sường này hết.
Mặt mặt a gi anybody có 5rent nem tộ isso
Đó, mặt và hả hả hả hả?
Hả hả hả hả hả?
Rồi, mặt mặt và đặcupun xem t REAL, Rồi gi recurs m deutsche cả better a
C mars thứ 2 steri bà íK g regarding tuyển polity.
Mà hả, b ему hả?
Rồi, đ ethical vàng cựp midan Chinese.
Đ thumbs thbench, GRACED BIRTH BANGAY
Vì con có người bệnh bị tám hiển.
Một nào nếu đâm vừa sợ qua bị em tởi im đó tụi nằm.
Còn hẹp thấy với sự chợi giữa vụ cám dụng đặt xem như không.
Hành chỉ về cuy ám thách của người dụng trở nên ăn pàn vượn mà
bất biến nó là trong 1 bàn nội nó ngay thách.
Con bà bà chờ nổi dí ra hành chỉ về cuy ám thách của mình rồi.